i think keep it fresh keep people
interested
well kim once called her the least
exciting to look at
she's the least exciting to look at
we've always been interested in all
things courtney k
we are just so fabulous we're so smart
we're so
gorgeous we're so such great business
women
she's the original kardashian sister who
keeps everyone in line
it's actually kind of annoying how much
of a perfectionist i am and shares
so much there's no forgetting her giving
birth
on tv
[Music]
courtney's journey into and through
motherhood has been must see tv
for more than a decade for me you know
my son was born
so it was definitely the most amazing
year probably in my entire life
i feel like my weekends are like this is
what it's all about
it's kid stuff and you know
i love it and i think it makes
my weekend's hole first comes family
then comes the family business from
fashion
be passionate about whatever you do and
if you are passionate about it it really
comes across and then it's not work
i can't imagine doing this without my
sisters
so maybe team up with your family
members if you can stand them and love
them as much as we love each other
every time we're doing something like a
lunch or
at a signing and i'm we're always like
oh no one's going to show up or
something and then
there's always an overwhelming response
and it's
like we always pinch ourselves like is
this real it's just
all such a dream come true to health and
fitness i need to read every label
like i was like trying to find like all
these healthy things
you are like slowest in 2019 the reality
star launched her own
lifestyle brand push a platform designed
to give women
wellness advice and share eco-friendly
products she uses in her own life it's
also no secret
court has always kept it real brunettes
are not calm
like what are you doing well you girls
are not calm no we're not
i take the shortest because i tell
everyone you have 30 minutes with me
whatever i look like after that
is what i'm gonna look like because i
could care less to
take too long like i've finally gotten
to the place where i'm like i used to
try to be like
don't say that in front of this person
or whatever and now i'm like honestly
what do i care like if people don't like
it
like see you later well i mean no one i
really can't
be perfect she i mean it's funny because
probably if someone else does like the
things she does i would hate them but
there's something i don't know what it
is i just think she's like the cutest
person in the world
and i don't think she's inside i like
find it like funny
how she's like i call her like she's
just stone cold or even just
like she's like yeah all right like
everything is the same reaction i
actually
am an emotional person she is fast
forward and courtney's views have not
changed one bit
i'm just like living life and whatever
happens happens